[Music]
it's this week we've got strongest Oh
wins this bet all over you sorry losing
champion and hungry childbirth take it
away
Tiffany yeah so for our first story did
you guys know that tell wrestling is
actual sport what country Russia Russia
Mongolia Mongolia toes who got the
thickest toe on knees man they throw up
with some interesting [ __ ] is there a
sexual version like oil till wrestling
I'm sure there is two toes in a mud bath
yeah I don't know if I could tall
wrestle I'd be giggling too much so this
country back in 1976 it was a group of
people that felt that this particular
country would never win and any sports
it illegal they were like you know we
got a creative sport what name is for
that they'd always wanted o shooting
what yeah they got their first Olympic
gold medal or something like that no
mate I don't know if it's gold but
they've got their first Olympic medal
the recent Olympics
oh [ __ ] from sharp shooting yeah
[Music]
[Music]
but that's like finally after how many
years the whole year but but [ __ ]
that's a cool sports to be placed in
after you won it wasn't even happier
they finally took me years now this
country it's the UK or England
what so apparently this we got crusty
toes out there why they wear shoes
exactly if it's all humid and thick and
cold and they wear their shoes inside
the house don't English people sleep
with boots on I picture the type of
English people you're thinking or
probably medieval peasants with like a
crusty toe that split in half something
in Asian people got the crusty because
they're always in [ __ ] sandals look
at my feet oh my god this is good I was
walking on the carpet clean he'll slide
his feet into the into the bedsheet this
carpets dirty new big pulled threaded
machine yeah that's awesome
these threads are [ __ ] shoots what
are the rules to this you have to keep
your heels down you know you're like
like thumb wrestle technically like
you're not supposed to be going like
this like you know our armless never
elbow it down are there rules to this
they do have rules are long Tony Oscar
or long Tony Oh like what's the point of
him working out he's actually won 14
times [ __ ]
just the recommendation oh that's
creating crown 14 times already
why is that gloves on so you have to
have your butt down on the floor okay
and your hands both have to be on the
ground and the leg that you're not
wrestling with has to be in the air Oh
he's not even touching the floor and his
legs off the floor on the floor maybe
just one maybe
well how do you win yeah so in the
middle in the center here I'm actually
gonna show you guys a video awesome you
gotta make a party toe wrestling haha
put your foot up it they put your foot
up
you guys are tall raffle hairy ass beat
whoa I like how they got the badass
music it's all tense oh my god
yeah junipers country wow wow yeah right
the WWE
the win Wow
oh my god there's a toy dude I love how
they edited that [ __ ] yeah I love how
they're trying to make this sports so
badass like arm wrestling or like some
combat sports they got like the rock
music going on and does like well that
was the New York Post that edited that
video but yeah I mean they're trying to
but it's like it's like I think thumb
war is a lot more badass yeah really
away it's just a battle of beat you know
it's it's just I don't know it just
seems cuter I wonder if there's a
regulations on size like what if we put
like Julia against like Josh josh is 15
this is Josh whole like half with like
ya know I think they do
line them up to match people's sizes
because I saw in this other video that
there was a kid wrestling another kid
you know what's weird palms don't smell
like feet do cuz they don't touch the
ground everywhere I guess and they're
not in a glove all day but what about
people that were sandals and they still
got thankful you they do smile cuz when
you wear your workout gloves don't your
workout gloves start smelling we are
boxing but not as bad well I mean
because you're not wearing it as much
but imagine now wearing it as long as
you aware like socks and shoes oh yeah
like if I had gloves on all day and I'm
all walking on my hands I'm have stinky
hands those have toe jam yeah and then
they they're probably easier to get
funky
see that's why we need to wear barefoot
we need to wear better we need to wear
barefoot I'm just imagining shoes with
like bare feet yeah thank you
how do you win so in that center thing
that they have there's a line down the
middle and then the two walls so
apparently whoever you're wrestling with
you're trying to get them and West
I live and keep fighting in Yahoo and
they they're wrestling
I like whistling try in order to to when
they have to hit one of the walls oh
it's like it's like armwrestling but
first I had them balls
hey grub with like a long toenail count
as a weapon like in [ __ ] fights you know
they have like that mom I think I'll
[ __ ] Vaseline the [ __ ] out of my foot
yeah because that's what wrestlers do
Ryan fighters they grease the [ __ ]
body up yeah maybe they have rules
against those cheatin ass [ __ ] how do
you tell people that with a pride like
hey girl I'm a toe wrestling champion
she's like oh my god it's probably one
of those things where you don't tell
anyone but there's a groupie for
everything though that's really weird
it's true all right for our next story
do you get or first of all do you guys
know who John Jonesy yes yes he is the
light heavyweight champion of UFC oh and
there's a fight coming up it already
came DUP yes I know he just beat Daniel
Cormier like and I heard all the
controversies behind the Daniel Cormier
oh yeah yeah and that's what we're
talking about the controversy with you
gotta work hot steam boyd's
yeah so John Jones he's widely regarded
as one of the greatest MMA fighters of
all time very true yeah he has several
records in this division but his entire
career has been surrounded by a lot of
controversy so like for example back in
2015 he got fined $25,000 for testing
positive for cocaine and he was allowed
to keep his title and he had a
squeaky-clean image too at that time
when he was considered like the boy next
door that just came up really hard and
really fought outside of them it's
always those squeaky clean ones
imagine Taylor Swift catch testing
positive for cocaine that's what
happened I'm okay with that believe it
yeah yeah and then April 2015 year's
charged with the felony hit-and-run he
got in a car accident he injured a
pregnant woman who broke her arm
he ended up fleeing the scene he got
caught that's worse than cocaine he was
stripped of his title then and he was
removed that's funny how he doesn't
panic in a fight but he panics after
accident he doesn't know what to do in
the real world I know yeah because most
people can't [ __ ] fight a
professional fighter in a ring and not
panic yeah extension cords in the vacuum
cleaner yeah I guess with that whole
hitter up thing he lost a lot of
sponsorships like he he didn't fight for
a while
must really suck for Nike just cuz they
had Tiger Woods and uh and Kobe right
they both were like in crazy scandals
and now this guy Coco's after the fact
Kobe was with adidas and so he got
dropped for a couple of years in the
night keeping him back up on his prime
prime just don't sponsor nobody Nike
isn't us yeah we would never sponsor me
oh yeah they should get out of
sponsoring sports people because they're
scoundrels
you know they sponsored Kevin Hart oh
really he's the first comedian be
sponsored by the company that's cuz he
likes a jar it is hmm
yeah so anyways back to John John so he
returned to the UFC in 2016 but then he
was pulled from the rankings again after
testing positive for banned substances
three days before a fight he's saying
that him jested them by mistake and Ciao
Bella and went into my mouth and I
swallowed it honestly it happens quick
you quick explain here he was saying
that he was trying to take Cialis which
is like sleeping he was blaming it on
that he was trying to fight people with
a hard-on Danny so y'all know that's
because when you take all these other
things your dick doesn't work the same
so you have to take that helps with this
ground game it's it's for blood
circulation yeah just kidding it's like
ginseng notice feels good he's working
on his fifth limb oh my god now again he
tested positive for
performance-enhancing drugs do you know
which one it is they're just calling
percocet antibiotic anabolic anabolic
sorry anabolic steroid I heard people
who make him fly them because that's
like the cheap [ __ ] you couldn't get or
like if you were in do steroids why
don't you do the [ __ ] high-end stuff
yeah anabolic steroids is like the most
basic basic like that's the first thing
that is usually so how these things work
with professional organizations it's
here's a band and then so whatever you
were allowed to take before everyone's
gonna push the limits right cuz they're
trying to be a champion but as soon as
they increase the ban again now like the
ten substances turn it to 15 that you
can't take so it's always trying to
fight loopholes and the reason why I
like sometimes are the athletes when
they say I really didn't know and it's
actually an honest answer is because
these athletes they have to just control
their fighting and the discipline and
the training right and so they're
surrounded by a council so they have
like the nutritionist they have a doctor
they have whatever and all those guys
their careers Bank on the fighters to
win so if you have a doctor
that's like trust me this is the new
best [ __ ] you have to take it you just
believe them because they're they have
your best interest in mind and you don't
have the scientific knowledge that they
do so a lot of times we take this you
know recover in two days and then of
course you're not ever gonna think this
guy's gonna [ __ ] me over so there is a
huge possibility that he really didn't
know and it happens a lot but there's
also a possibility like with something
as basic as anabolic steroids he
probably did know because those anabolic
steroids there's like a feel like test
trend whatever and like all those things
are highly known and if it was like some
next-level [ __ ] that we never heard of
then it's a lot it's not to see how it
passed like but if it's just straight-up
here's a navarre take this it's like
everyone knows what that is no heroin
was illegal yeah but if it was like
here's kfj you know what the [ __ ] gay
FG and then I took could be trying to
know what that was you know detective
October's first time he tested positive
he was suspended for an entire year but
that now that he's tested positive again
you're saying that he could potentially
be suspended up to four years which is a
career-ending yeah thank in the UFC or
or just in any anti-doping testing
agency it's probably UFC cuz you know
what's crazy is John Jones is so [ __ ]
good like he's literally the best that
he could probably just jump to another
Federation and go to a pellet or
anywhere else and get paid just as much
he could turn into like a sideshow like
into it one of those circus type of us
see if he doesn't get paid just as much
mm-hmm cuz he's just he's literally the
best so people want to watch him fight
no matter what mm-hmm
yes Dana White was just saying that it
was really saddening because of the fact
that this kid has so much potential he
calls them kids but yes he is a kid to
him yeah to him so right now they're
retesting it if it comes back that it is
positive for the second time then he
will be banned for four years and Dana
White thing like that's career-ending
there because coming trying to do a
comeback at 34 it's not gonna happen
so why why did he do this he's like
literally he's on the road to being the
best MMA fight
ever lived and so he could have really
done something great what why we should
just let people do steroids I like that
it was a lot rougher when baseball was
like [ __ ] smashing it they don't want
the body but like Sammy Sosa and like
they just everyone's just knocking the
ball out of the park who's my [ __ ]
baseball's a [ __ ] and everyone's just
like jacked Oh what are we talkin to you
we were talking to someone that's hella
into baseball and held into fitness so
they were saying that during baseball's
Golden Ears with Sammy Sosa Barry Bonds
and like Mark McGwire and everyone had
like 20 inch arms that was baseball's
highest rating cuz the the ball was
flying out of the park it was just it
was exhilarating to watch these monsters
but nothing but isn't that win the
scandal with Darryl Strawberry or some
[ __ ] happened and he was caught format
steroids and all that [ __ ] yeah I was
like during that era but now now that
everyone's nati
and everyone looks really skinny and no
one's knocking the ball anywhere boy no
one's watching baseball and baseball is
a dying splinter my question is everyone
even Olympians everyone does stereos
stereos
like Cheerios with steroids everyone
does it right but they just cycle they
cycle off or they just find the [ __ ]
that is legal and they do that
performance-enhancing drugs is something
that all athletes do it's ready top tier
level it's very [ __ ] rare yeah and
like Bart said like at that level of
professionalism you are a corporation by
yourself yeah you are like kobe himself
is a company so like they already have
all these people like at that point
you're not doing your own training
rather no ones setting up your [ __ ]
you're not doing your own training
program you're not doing your own
nutrition you're not doing [ __ ] you just
show up and then people are telling you
what to do you're a [ __ ] puppet
you don't even stretch on your own so
there's an NBA past no patterns not
barbell yeah he doesn't he literally
lays on the phone with his cell phone
and his trainer comes and pushes his
legs for him puts his arm off your plate
you don't even stretch on your own
everyone is on it right so like why why
what's up even in fact it is no because
now that you don't have to so like
imagine you know when you massage
yourself it's only so effective right
but then it
you have a chiropractor massage so a
professional licensed stretcher is
stretching you and you don't have to do
jack [ __ ] like these athletes they don't
do anything they're literal corporation
like what Joe's saying and they're
surrounded by a team about 10 15 people
and it depends like people have this
idea of steroids being like oh you
[ __ ] take this [ __ ] and now you're
super mad and it's not fair it's like no
it just helps you heal faster
and recover so you could train harder
yeah people always think it's just like
this magic thing that happens you take
and all the sudden you're like Popeye
and fit it doesn't it doesn't take away
from the work ethic like people still
got a trained [ __ ] hard but it helps
them recover faster build muscle fast
they're all that rest less stuff yeah
they're gonna die fast and [ __ ] and it's
like but we're watching yeah well like
we're watching them not to be model
citizens we're watching them to be our
gladiators right like yeah there's the
entertainer why the [ __ ] do people have
to have good morals and [ __ ] like like
it's people's fault to treat these guys
as gods and more all like oh I got to
look up to this person because I want
them it's like what the [ __ ] like pick
other people to be your morale like
heroes you know like and then you know
musicians and all these people let them
do what they do best like who gives a
[ __ ] if this musician is sucking 50
dicks a day like that doesn't make their
music suck it you know like why do we
have to this person has to be perfect
yeah it's like they have to be a role
model for children nah dude [ __ ]
parents should be role models
[ __ ] if you can't be a [ __ ]
role model they're gonna watch JK news
and I'm gonna influence the [ __ ] out of
these kids you don't want that no yes
you do
I heard the guy that he fought for me is
like probably pissed because his fight
with him gave him really terrible I
guess like brain damage not brain damage
but I didn't watch the fight but this is
the second time you lost him yeah like
some sort of like very permanent damage
so now he's finding out that it's due to
steroids or whatever he's probably
pissed hands-down though with or without
steroids I think Jon Jones is a better
fighter so I don't even know why he took
it like I think Jon Jones has a lack of
confidence yeah he could have just you
could have beat him
maybe we should have one that says like
the steroid sports like you could do all
of [ __ ] steroids you want to this is
the uncontrolled one right yeah and we
have like the clean sports like we
should we should do that no but you know
it's gonna happen though there's gonna
be a lot of athletes that are probably
gonna take too much and then they're
gonna die and then there's gonna be a
ban against them again that's their
fault
yeah cuz back in the beat right that
should be a great example see this is
what happens to you when you [ __ ]
overdo things you die mm-hmm for our
last story
you guys might relate to this one so
there was this couple in North Carolina
they were about to give birth to their
Oh literally us to they're about to give
birth or the mom she was in labor about
to give birth to her third kid when the
dad was saying that he was hungry
mmm decided to do a little detour on
their way to the hospital make sure that
stop by a chick-fil-a to get oh that
makes sense though wait she was in labor
my mom was like in labor and then and
then she told my dad and then my dad was
like okay hold on let me take a shower
first and my mom was like I'm in labor
we need to go and he was like all right
can we get McDonald's first my mom was
like I'm in labor we need to go home who
was the kid huh it was my brother oh
that's good dad too [ __ ] crazy so I
don't need that sponsorship we don't you
would stop giving birth just for you
there's gonna give you [ __ ] you should
stop by McDonald's on your way to labor
I have a theory that the only reason why
we're not being sponsored is because of
G oh yeah you know what McDonald's like
I think we're secret friends cuz they
follow me on Instagram and they follow
me on Twitter you don't Twitter they
they go this thing what they follow you
yeah so they know I'm there but they're
just like but your girl's friends so
[ __ ] you yeah all of our friends around
us McDonald fix it so you're trying to
pick McDonald's over G oh yeah of course
you were there for me in my childhood G
OH
you did invite me you even know existed
yeah but husband was saying it was
actually they're on their way for their
fourth kids my bed I said third but
anyways so they were already done it
three other times right they were just
like yeah you know if you want
chick-fil-a workers to work fast on your
order just tell him your wife is in
labor cuz that works and apparently like
the wife was gonna quote she was like
yeah me we've done this three other
times he was hungry
it was fine do you think by the third
kid you're like [ __ ] it all my time in
labor I know I got like eight more hours
to go
probably because I would have been
panicking like maybe wait was that your
first kid was I mean was that your dad's
first kid it was oh and he was so chill
about it can I take a shower oh you know
your dad got other baby mamas in oh yeah
she works for [ __ ] barbel no or Mary
all that the waiting people get thinking
you guys are the same person
do it even a freaking Davids like secret
society event like me and Mary we like
actually dressed up almost the same and
she was like again yeah I should like
dude literally I was about to wear the
same exact outfit as you were I'm like
shut up get the [ __ ] out of here and
then and then people thought the whole
night they're like did you guys plan
this or something you were like no we
did it
you and Mary all look nothing like alike
though how is that even possible
in the wedding vlog they were sitting
behind me along same here we dress you
like a cardigan hope you guys enjoyed
that video but if you didn't guess what
you can directly contribute to the
articles that we discussed just cruise
on over to the description box below
click on that link to submit your
article also for the next video click
right up hey
[Music]